how about could there be on the horizon
a same leader a guy who knows what he's
doing who's younger who has a track
record who says stuff and then does
stuff and is also laying out a vision
for the future yeah Ron DeSantis we need
to fundamentally reconstitutionalize the
government you know we talked about
draining the swamp in 2016 that didn't
happen I think the better analogy is
breaking the swamp because you can drain
it a little bit next guy can fill it
back in so we're going to fundamentally
reshape Washington
doj to the FBI IRS that requires a
president that's disciplined that's
determined and that's not going to get
distracted and take their eye off the
ball are you in favor of eliminating any
agencies I know conservatives in the
past have talked about closing the
Department of Education would you do
that
so we would do education we would do
Commerce we do energy and we would do
IRS and so if Congress will work with me
on doing that we'll be able to reduce
eliminate the size and scope of
government but what I'm also going to do
Martha is be prepared if Congress won't
go that far I'm going to use those
agencies to push back against woke
ideology and against the leftism that we
see creeping into all institutions of
America clear competent it's all there
what is he going to do he's going to
eliminate the Department of Education
the Department of Commerce Department of
energy the IRS I like how she was kind
of like the IRS like all right yeah that
would be good and as he said even if he
can't get Congress to fully do it
there's other ways you can start
breaking the swamp and also the line
that I really loved was at the top
[Music]
reconstitutionalize the government that
by the way is what just happened this
morning we started
reconstitutionalizing the United States
of America we've removed systemic racism
in the name of defending the
Constitution which is about equal rights
and equal opportunity and all that
foreign
[Music]